[Music]
hey Wolfgang hope everybody's doing well
and hope everybody has went and seen a
vendor's infinity war by now and if you
haven't I hope you get to go see it soon
if you haven't seen it I'm sorry there
will be some spoilers in this video
about Avengers infinity war and I'm
sorry that most of them have been on
infinity war if you haven't seen them I
can see how that sucks
I promise there's different videos
coming up really soon so having given
you the spoiler alert we are going to
start talking about the topic of this
video and that is Corvus glaive what I
want to talk about in this video is
actually the question is Corvus glaive
really dead now I know some of you were
thinking what are you talking about we
clearly saw visions stabbed him right
through the chest with his own glaive
and watched him die and I want to argue
with you
that did happen but for those of you who
don't know Corvus glaive is actually
immortal kind of Corvus glaive is
immortal as long as his glaive is intact
and I didn't see vision destroy the
glaive after he killed Corvus glaive
with it so again that leaves the
question is he really dead now it was
never mentioned in the movie that Corvus
glaive was immortal if his glaive stayed
intact but then again Doc Dean about the
black order was really mentioned so we
really don't know if he in fact does
have the ability to be immortal in the
MCU if they don't given the same
abilities that he has in the comics then
they might not give him this ability to
be immortal if it's a glaive is intact
and if that's the case then I'm saying
yes he's dead and after all Proxima
midnight spear is supposed to never miss
and in the movie Captain America just
kind of grabs it like it's nothing and
then uses it against Proxima midnight
and Corvus glaive while fighting them
but if you notice that when she throws
it and Captain America catches it she is
in shock so maybe they're just trying to
give Captain America more credit here
because her spear did shoot energy beams
of light like it does in the comics and
it does leave a poison based on what we
know from the fight scene because when
Black Widow stabs Corvus glaive he can't
get up she asked him to get up and he
says I can't this is highly believed to
be the poison and Proxima midnight spear
causing them to not
be able to fight this is from the comics
as well so maybe they're just not
stating it but they are in fact giving
these weapons the same power that they
have in the comics so if they have the
same powers that they have in the comics
then Corvus glaive is not dead because
his glove is still intact
keeping him alive actually makes a lot
of sense because they could use this
story for adventures for in the comics
Corvus glaive actually forms his own
black order then Thanos returns and they
both battle for supremacy and Thanos is
obviously a lot stronger than Corvus
glaive if he wasn't then Thanos would be
in the black order and everybody would
be following Corvus glaive so needless
to say santos beats Corvus glaive and
Corvus glaive not wanting Thanos to kill
him himself takes his broken glaive
which Stannis broke and kills himself
since the glaive is broken he is no
longer immortal and he dies
so again this is just one way that they
could take Avengers for and I personally
think he's still alive I think they
would leave that part from the comics
in the movies so the final answer to the
question that I ultimately asked myself
is Corvus glaive really dead my answers
no I don't think he is I'm not saying
they're gonna follow the same storyline
as the comics and he's gonna go against
Stannis in Avengers 4 but I don't think
he's dead because his glaive is still
intact which means he's still immortal
but that's just my theory let me know
what you guys think do you think he's
dead or do you think his glaive has the
same powers that it does in the comics
let me know your thoughts in the
comments below and if you like this
video please give it a thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to my channel
to join the wolf gang also don't forget
about our giveaway for a free speaker
system all you have to do to enter is
subscribe to my channel subscribe to the
stupendous wave leave a like and drop a
comment below with your favorite
superhero from Marvel DC or otherwise
thank you so much for watching Wolf Wolf
you